Por qué estos tanques pueden marcar un
punto de inflexión en la guerra en
palabras sencillas Qué tienen tanto los
leopardos como los abrams que no tienen
los tanques que ya usa el ejército
ucraniano
bueno son tanque de una tecnología
moderna que contienen adentro por
supuesto hay elementos de seguridad
operacional pero en términos generales
contienen la capacidad de mantener
Comando y control de identificar
objetivos de guiar de día de noche en
mal tiempo con poca visibilidad y que
tienen un gran alcance con sus
armamentos con tanto con la
ametralladora o con el cañón de gran
poder que que cargan
el leopark es un poco más fácil de
manejar y de recibir entrenamiento en él
el Abraham en one es un poco más
complicado sin embargo los ucranianos
han demostrado que tienen una gran
capacidad y un gran deseo de defender a
su país y no tengo duda de que tendrán
la capacidad de manejarlos a propósito
de esto Qué hay sobre el entrenamiento
de estos vehículos cuánto pueden tardar
los soldados ucranianos en aprender a
manejarlos
bueno el entrenamiento puede ocurrir
inmediatamente porque a estos equipos lo
pueden utilizar dentro de Europa es
cuestión de mover a los soldados
ucranianos a Europa y recibir
entrenamiento allí o en Estados Unidos
que anteriormente ya el pentágono ha
informado que se han estado entrenando
soldados ucranianos en Estados Unidos
así que no hay que esperar para que el
equipo llegue a Ucrania que va a tomar
algunos meses en el caso de los
por la cuestión logística para que
comience ese entrenamiento debe comenzar
prontamente expertos mencionaban por
ejemplo que el número de tanques
entregados a Ucrania es clave es
suficiente la cifra que se ha anunciado
hasta ahora para lograr un Impacto
significativo
Más allá de la cantidad evidentemente no
es el número que había pedido el
presidente de salinsky el presidente
celins que había pedido trescientos
tanques esta cantidad es muy inferior a
eso no creo que llegue en algún momento
a trescientos pero más allá de la
cantidad Yo creo que el hecho que
Alemania haya aceptado proveer estos
tanques de alto poder de alta tecnología
a Ucrania
demuestra la capacidad que tiene y el la
dedicación y la determinación de apoyar
a Ucrania a pesar de las amenazas
nucleares de Putin ahora porque la
reticencia a enviarlos en un primer
momento
por la historia Cuando vemos la historia
de Alemania Alemania viene de la Segunda
Guerra Mundial es donde no salieron como
pueblo verdad no Salieron muy bien
parados en la historia tiene unas
limitaciones constitucionales también y
tienen una limitaciones culturales en
términos de envolverse en otro tipo de
conflicto y el Primer Ministro tendría
que ser estaba obligado a ser muy
sensitivo a esa a esa circunstancias
antes de tomar un paso pero entiendo yo
que están en el lado correcto de la
historia ya que lo que están defendiendo
en Ucrania son los mismos ideales que
viven en Alemania